one of the more puzzling aspects of the
way we're built is that our emotional
development does not necessarily or
automatically keep pace with our
physical growth we can be 55 on the
outside and four and a half in terms of
our impulses and manner of communicating
just as we can be on the threshold of
adulthood physically while an emotional
sage within in order to assess our own
and others emotional development we can
make use of a single deceptively simple
question that quickly gets to the core
of our underlying emotional age when
someone on whom we depend emotionally
lets us down disappoints us or leaves us
hanging and uncertain what is a
characteristic way of responding there
are three methods which indicate
emotionally immature behavior we might
grade ourselves on a scale of 1 to 10
according to our propensity z' firstly
we might sulk that is we simultaneously
get very upset while refusing to explain
to the person who has upset us what the
problem might actually be the insult to
our pride and dignity feels too great we
are too internally fragile to reveal
that we've been knocked we hope against
hope that another person might simply
magically understand what they've done
and fix it without us needing to speak
rather as an infant who hasn't yet
mastered language might have a hope that
a parent would spontaneously enter their
minds and just guess what was ailing
them secondly we might get furious
another response is to get extremely and
disproportionately angry with the
disappointing person our fury may look
powerful but no one who felt powerful
would have any need for such titanic
rage inside we feel broken at sea and
bereft but our only way of reasserting
control is to mimic an aggrieved Emperor
or taunted tiger our insults and
viciousness are in their coded ways
admissions of terror and defenselessness
our pain is profoundly poignant a manner
of
dealing with it a good deal sadder
thirdly we might go cold it takes a lot
of courage to admit to someone who's
hurt us that we care that they have a
power over us that a key bit of our life
is in their hands
it may be a lot easier to put up a
strenuous wall of indifference at
precisely the moment when we are most
emotionally vulnerable to a loved ones
behavior we insist that we haven't
noticed a slight and wouldn't give a
damn anyway we may not simply be
pretending remaining in touch with our
wounds may have become conclusively
intolerable not feeling anything may
have replaced the enormous threat of
being fully alive these three responses
pointers in turn to the three markers of
emotional maturity firstly the capacity
to explain that is the power simple to
describe but a proper accomplishment in
practice to explain why we are upset to
the person who's upset us to have faith
that we can find the words that we are
not pathetic or wretched for suffering
in a given way and that with a bit of
luck we will find the words to make
ourselves understood by someone whom we
can remember deep down even at this
moment of stress is not our enemy
secondly the capacity to stay calm the
mature person knows that robust self
assertion is always an option down the
line this gives them the confidence not
to need to shout immediately to give
others the benefit of every doubt and
not to assume the worst and then hit
back with undue force the mature like
themselves enough not to suspect that
everyone would have a good reason to
mock and slander them thirdly the
capacity to be vulnerable the mature
know and have made their peace with the
idea that being close to anyone will
open them up to being hurt they feel
enough inward strength to possess a
tolerable relationship with their own
weakness they are unembarrassed enough
by their emotional nakedness to tell
even the person who has apparently
humiliated them that they are in need of
help
they trust ultimately that there is
nothing wrong with their tears and that
they have the right to find someone who
will know how to bear them in turn these
three traits belong to what we can call
the three cardinal virtues of emotional
maturity communication trust and
vulnerability these three virtues were
either gifted to us during a warm and
nourishing childhood or else we will
need to learn them arduously as adults
this is akin to the difference between
growing up speaking a foreign language
and having to learn it over many months
as an adult
however the comparison at least gives us
an impression of the scale of the
challenge ahead of us there is nothing
to be ashamed of about our possible
present ignorance at least half of us
weren't brought up in the land of
emotional literacy we may just never
have heard adults around us speaking an
emotionally mature dialect so we may
despite our age need to go right back to
school and spend five to ten thousand
hours learning with great patience and
faith the beautiful and complex grammar
of the language of emotional adulthood
our emotional barometer is a tool that
can help us to more clearly explain our
moods click the link on screen now to
find out more
you